and so today we're going to talk about
something fun we're going to talk about
innovation in healthcare and in part
through tell you the story of oculi at
the company that I founded co-founded
out of Stanford to treat dry eye disease
and it won't be a surprise to most of
you if anyone has read the news in the
last couple of years you know that
healthcare is changing right so we're
seeing increased expenses and there's a
lot of things that are changing in the
environment as a result of that it may
even be hit in your own pocketbook but
what I thought we would do is just look
at the change by the numbers so the
graph on the left here shows healthcare
spending as a fraction of our GDP over
the last 50 years you'll see that it's
going up into the right and 2014 the
last year for which data was available
from the government we spent seventeen
point five percent of the GDP seventeen
point five percent of the entire gross
domestic product on health care spending
and it's down three trillion dollars and
we're feeling it right I mean so we're
starting to hear about pressure on
prices we're starting to hear about
health care premiums going up as some of
that cost getters shift to the patients
and we're hearing about it in terms of
consolidation in the industry another
phenomenon is happening so the plot on
the right actually shows the fraction of
Americans that are insured right and
you'll notice in the last couple of
years and largely because of the
Affordable Care Act there's a very large
increase in the number of Americans that
are insured as well I do believe that
even under a trump presidency there's
going to be some impetus to provide a
program for driving insurance amongst
the population so what's happening is
that we're we're running out of room for
growth in health care spending we have
more people who need to be treated and
we're all starting to feel the pinch
right and so we're feeling it as
patients and we're certainly feeling it
in the industry so our government also
makes available the expenditure in terms
of where there's three trillion dollars
is going so let's take a look so more
than half of that three trillion dollars
is going to hospitals that's going to
doctors in their clinics
about 9% of its going to drug companies
about 3% of it is going to medical
device companies and then a series of
other things including I think notably a
7% that actually just goes literally to
support the infrastructure of the
insurance companies and the federal
Medicare and Medicaid and every slice in
this pie is feeling it and so there is
Drive on every single one of these - to
start becoming more efficient and we can
see that in terms of consolidation and
so what's happening on the private
practices are being brought up and
consolidated into hospitals we see
hospitals that largely had been
independent for a long period of time
consolidating into hospital systems both
regional and national we're seeing
consolidation and the drug companies
we're seeing consolidation and the
insurance companies into the device
companies as well and all of this is in
an effort to drive more efficiency in
the system so let's look at another
dimension so now we know where the
dollars are being spent you know what is
being spent on so according to the CDC
an astounding 86 percent of this three
trillion dollars is being spent on
management of chronic diseases and so
that chronic if his chronic diseases
include things like heart disease and
diabetes some types of cancer but it
also includes things like dry eye
disease which is what our company was
focused on I'm is something that I'll
tell you more about and so what does all
this mean well something that's sending
a little bit of a shudder through the
industry is frankly that there's going
to be a higher bar right in terms of
providing efficient treatment and so
that's the the technologies that are
more expensive for incremental benefit
I'm frankly probably aren't going to get
into the marketplace anymore and at
least not as easily and so that's the
bad news
but what's the good news is that there's
a heck of a lot of opportunity out there
so you have this three trillion dollar
marketplace this enormous industry that
is literally changing under our feet
right now and there's huge opportunity
because someone has to be an agent for
that change right
tremendous opportunity in this
consolidation as well so one of the
things we'll talk about a bit that has
actually hindered some of this this
change and changed by technology is that
there's very separate groups right I
mean you go get your your broken leg
fixed by one physician you get your eyes
fixed someplace else and your primary
care physician who may have referred you
to these places can't even look up with
new medical records to see exactly how
that went
right so that consolidation actually can
be a real opportunity as well
particularly on the information
technology sign and then layer it on all
this there's really a tremendous
opportunity in chronic disease and so
providing better or frankly just more
efficient ways to care for chronic
disease so logos of our friends and
neighbors here in Silicon Valley right
over here were used to all this
technology coming in and completely
transforming a marketplace right I mean
it's the way that we connect it's the
way that we buy goods the way that we
get around the way we interface with the
world and we're used to these these big
technologies coming in and making a real
difference right but here healthcare
seventeen and a half percent gross
domestic product and none of those logos
are a health care company right and it's
been very very slow to be to be
converted by big technology so why is
that the case well there's a few reasons
so one is that there's a very complex
network of consumers so if you're Amazon
it's very clear here consumer is this
the person who is buying the goods right
that well and in healthcare it's a
little different you have the patient is
what we typically think about this is
someone who is either being diagnosed or
being treated but frankly a lot of the
time they're not even the one who's
making the decision as to which product
to use right a decision is oftentimes
being made or at least heavily
influenced by a health care practitioner
this is the doctors the nurses the
technicians these health care providers
very typically operate in a hospital our
hospital system and so that hospital
also has tremendous decision-making
ability over what products are used for
the patients and by the practitioners
within there
within their system so yet another
decision that you and frankly all of
these people are actually paying for any
of it right it's all paid for by an
insurance company or pay forward by the
federal government Medicare and Medicaid
so yet another customer that's to decide
that this is the right the right
technology to use there's also highly
regulated industry so you also have to
satisfy the FDA and they have their own
sets of needs and requirements and it's
also an industry that's very heavily
influenced by the professional medical
societies so these are societies that
provide guidance to the practicing
public you know what are the what's the
best practice to use and you cannot use
and they also have a very heavily
influence over the payer system as well
so what products actually ultimately end
up getting getting paid for and make the
list so okay why don't we have Amazon of
healthcare well one of the reasons this
is very complex network of of consumers
why else
well it's also a very conservative and
industry by nature right and that's
actually probably justified so we're
talking about people's health if we make
bad decisions there are very real and
bad consequences for it so every
physician before they start practicing
they take the Hippocratic oath and they
vow to first do no harm and that
attitude actually pervades not only than
the physician community but the FDA in
industry as well so it's everyone wants
to make sure that things are safe
another thing is that medical innovation
you know oftentimes relies on new
science and sometimes new science
happens a lot slower than new software
and so it could be be a tough thing to
go there we have a distributive provider
system and meaning as I mentioned before
you go one one place for your for your
knee and another place for your eyes
another place for your heart same thing
with the payer system all these
different payers all over the place and
then also finally both ethical and legal
privacy concerns as well so bigots no
wonder why we haven't seen this big
enormous flash right
haven't seen someone come in and just
completely transform this healthcare
space but what really excites me and
what I think you should really excite
you and I'm hoping that if you even the
audience will will want to take a good
hard look at healthcare because frankly
I mean this is really a once in a career
type shift or opportunity what we are
starting to see is a lot of little
splashes now we're going to start seeing
a heck of a lot more than that so coming
into one disease space at a time coming
and attacking one efficiency
inefficiency at a time and this is
really going to start snowballing so for
the rest of today I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about oculi this
company that I spun out of Stanford with
some others this is the device that we
developed for treating dry eye disease
take a good look at it because it's not
the device that we started with so
that's all part of the story too and so
bio design is it's this Center over in
the Clark Clark center so right down
right down campus drive and it's just a
really neat space and so the plug there
is that they also have an undergraduate
and graduate course sequence in addition
to this fellowship that that I was a
part of and so I would encourage you to
take a look at it and what they've done
is they've taken this philosophy that I
think has really provided a lot of
Silicon Valley in the last couple of
decades that also was developed here
this empathy based design so this is by
David Kelly and Tom Kelly other folks at
the d.school here at Stanford really
formalized this process and the idea is
that by going and understanding the
consumer right and getting any empathy
for them then you can really understand
what their needs are and develop a
solution for that need in the healthcare
space paul Yaak and Josh Mack our the
founding faculty of bio design took that
same principle and brought it to health
care and in health care again the
consumer is a little more complex so
you've got this network and by the same
principle turns out to be really
powerful so the mantra there is a great
clinical need is the at the DNA of a
great solution
and healthcare for a long time we've
talked about bench-to-bedside and this
is where you've got this great
scientific idea and we have a way we're
going to now convert this into clinical
practice right and that's been really
that one of the mainstays of innovation
in healthcare and and frankly it's still
still very important right the catch is
you have to have a great scientific
innovation in order for that to work
right so unlike me I certainly didn't I
came into bio design with three other
people in our group of four it was quite
literally assigned to go innovate in
ophthalmology right I didn't know
anything about the eyeball I knew I had
to and that they were important to me
but frankly I was a little disappointed
I was like the size of a ping-pong ball
you know what could possibly be going on
in there I'm sure everything's already
fixed and fortunately I was very naive
and but we're by design teaches and
again it's this empathy based design is
this really bedside to bench to bedside
so you go back unless you already
happened to be sitting on this great and
important discovery and you can go back
and say hey look what are the needs
right we know that there's this huge
driving force in healthcare in terms of
efficiency that can really be the seat
and the the tidal wave for a lot of that
as well so here we are this is our group
before brandon was an engineer and
Victor McCray is a surgeon and Garret
Smith was an engineer and scientist and
again we were assigned ophthalmology to
go to go innovate something one of my
favorite things about Stanford and I'm
sure you guys are experiencing this
already but this is just it's incredible
because you have a question about
something in like the world's complete
expert is literally two buildings down
or it's a you just go talk in the door
you talk to somebody
we actually got very fortunate that
there was a very passion in an
innovative MBA student I also happen to
be an ophthalmologist and in fact a
specialist in dry eye she had spent
additional trainings and specifically
studying this and so we partnered up
with her bond antigen as well
so as part of this bio design program
there's this immersion right so first
you gotta go get the empathy right so we
spent four weeks and we literally just
watch clinical care so we sat around we
goofed off a little bit this is Garrett
here empathizing was sitting in the
patient's chair but we watched patients
come in and we watched physicians do
surgery and we watched what the issues
were and I was just amazed frankly and
by coming in with a very naive
beginner's mind but how quickly it is
you can start identifying issues
identifying in efficiencies and
identifying opportunities so in the
short three to four weeks have
identified some 347 unmet clinical needs
we went through a filtering process that
was primarily looking at what is a real
clinical problem what represents a
bonafide commercial opportunity I dry
eye disease and if you're a little bit
like me the first time I thought I heard
it wrong I was like dry eye disease I
really am is this a real problem and
turns out it is so if you were watching
television last night you may be we've
seen some commercials for some dry eye
drugs and that's because 8% of the
population has dry eye primarily
postmenopausal woman and it ranges from
something that can be a bit of a
nuisance to something that frankly is
very debilitating so it actually a
really phenomenal public public health
impact in a big market and so our real
insight here that what would we and came
up with and what kind of allowed us to
hang on to something that was kind of
special is that at the time and I think
frequently still people think about dry
eye in terms of this very complex system
that's going on there's 40 boxes you
know in this model and there's 80 arrow
is pointing around all the things that
are happening and frankly what we said
is okay but if you boil it down there's
really only two boxes in two rows okay
the body is not making enough of the
tear and the tear is very important it
helps help your cornea clear so you can
stay clear so you can see nurses the eye
and if we're not making enough of it or
some part of it then
the eye becomes dry and inflamed and the
more inflamed it becomes the less able
your body is able to make these do the
this tear and kind of run right around
to go in this cycle and what's
interesting as when we layered the
pharmaceutical industry on top of this
and the device industry which frankly
there there was very little happening in
all of the the people and that were
focusing on innovation for the last 20
years things in the marketplace things
in the pipeline everything was focused
in that left box
okay everybody was attacking
inflammation and no one not for 20 years
had had someone gone and actively looked
at restoring these natural constituents
of the tear film so that along with just
frankly some muscle in terms of going in
and understanding the anatomy and what's
going on we kind of had this aha moment
where we said okay look maybe we can use
electrical stimulation to activate the
nerves that innervate these structures
and get the body to make its own tear
again okay so now we've got this great
idea right what it's reading is
electrical stimulation and we're gonna
activate this nerve we got this really
cool thing and that we can't believe
nobody's thought of and and what our
thought was if we were gonna directly
activate the lacrimal gland and we were
going to do something or literally this
is an image that we showed some doctors
and we're gonna take this like a
pacemaker-like device we're going to
take a wire we're gonna run it under the
skin up the neck and then plug this in a
very thin wire of course and though we
were gonna then plug into the orbit or
the eye socket and the reception was not
good
so we show this the first doctor we
showed just about passed out and said
whatever you do don't show the patients
and and so we iterated and we brought
this one in and the thought was okay
look yeah we now we're gonna move to
much smaller device and maybe the issue
was the net hold neck thing whatever and
we'll move it back here and then we'll
run the wire up right well very similar
response I was like okay I don't think
you guys are getting it and the first
time that we started getting nodding
heads was when we brought I brought this
and and the upper right would you see
his
a piece of black plastic with some green
modelling clay on it and that was our
first prototype for what ultimately
became the implant that's sitting below
it the idea here was that it was an
injectable implant that would sit next
to the lacrimal gland the gland that
makes the majority of this tear and it
was gonna act like a little pacemaker
and again having looked at you know
where we ended up something something
must've gone sideways with this one
right we didn't end up with it I mean
I'll tell you about that but so now
we're kind of going into the the second
year here at Stanford okay identified
some new partners and so Jim Loudoun was
a postdoc in the physics department mark
bloom and Krantz and Daniel pellicer and
faculty here at Stanford and we were
able to raise some money so basis was
mentioned earlier we were forced enough
to get a $25,000 check from the the
basis competition and put a little bit
of money in the bank we're able to use
that to to get some venture backseat
capital and do some really work so I'm
gonna take a pause here because what I'm
telling you it sounds like a very linear
story right we go out we're gonna go
into clinic find some D's we got this
great deed now we're gonna go and come
up with a solution to it you know that's
terrific now we're just gonna you know
just go raise some money and then that
all work out and then move forward and
it retrospectively you can draw a
straight line through every one of those
points right but what you don't see is
there's a lot of other points on that
too and so this was actually a very
difficult time and this was a stressful
time there was a group work we're trying
to figure out do we want to be
entrepreneurs or do we want to go work
for a company right and so what I'd like
to do is talk a little bit about
managing personal risk and something
that for those of you who are interested
in entrepreneurship or sitting in this
room I think is very relevant and part
of the reason that are bringing it up is
because often times I see young
entrepreneurs I'm thinking but I believe
anyway to be probably unreasonable risk
and sometimes going all-in on something
that is very very high risk
and so at least want to pose a couple of
thoughts and kind of swing back the
other way in terms of what you can do to
manage that risk as an individual all
right so you're thinking you know do I
want to do a lot of it
you'll help be this entrepreneur or do I
want to go go and perhaps work for one
or work for another company and so I'm
gonna give you some unsolicited advice
but I think hopefully it'll be helpful
for you so the first thing is say I'm
considered an opportunity cost right so
I've seen a lot of young faces in the
room which makes me think that the vast
majority of you are students right so
you wouldn't be here if you weren't very
capable and didn't have a lot of
opportunity right so by jumping in I
going all then on something you're you
really are there's a cost to that so
you're giving up and something that
might be there and just to kind of plug
that side now that I've been it out
again for a year and a half I realized
that frankly are a lot of opportunities
at big companies right so there's a
really tremendous opportunity make
impact because these companies are
actually already in the marketplace and
they're there with the customers there's
a lot of opportunity to innovate within
these companies because they have
resources and also personal growth
because you're being taught by people
who do something really well on the
other hand if you have something that's
interesting if it's something that you
really have the bug you have good people
around you and getting encouragement for
a month then then give it a go it's
something that I used to describe it as
it's 90% of the time we're living the
dream and 10% of the time it's your
misery and there's there's nothing
in-between and but that's a pretty
decent decent trade-off there but what I
would recommend is to the extent
possible hedge so if you're thinking
about starting a company you're in a
really great position right now and
because you're at Stanford or you know
perhaps you're working someplace else I
noticed similar situation this is the
best incubator in the world right and
it's the best incubator for you in
particular not only because of all the
resources that are here and all the
people that are here
but also because if something doesn't
work out right a year later and this
thing goes belly-up your next employer
all they know is that you were really
involved and interested student at
Stanford who had this great side project
of something going on is really creative
right and and if instead you kind of go
all-in on something and it doesn't work
out whether the story is a little bit
more complex so all right so enough of
that what I will do is kind of talk to
you about what we did and for being for
our group and we set a threshold and
said okay look we're coming up on this
two-year mark we're about to be released
slash punted from campus right so what
so what happens then and we want to set
a threshold because frankly I was
applying for jobs at the same time right
I didn't know what was going to happen
and cultivating relationships because it
was uncertain and for us our threshold
was was really raising a bona fide
series-a and I'm not saying that this is
should be the same threshold for
everyone because everyone every story is
different but and the reasons that we
chose this is primarily because if we
were able to get real money into the
company then we could set have a much
higher probability of success right
that's because there's capital that's
because we've got better people around
the table I have people who are
experienced and know what they're doing
and frankly on the worst case side and
you know it is a really great experience
right and group getting experience
manage of a project managing individuals
with Sarah so in our case what we needed
was basically data showing that the
device the device works and fortunately
in our case it did so we did some minute
early animal work and actually some even
early clinical work and we were able to
raise a pretty solid series a43 venture
firms kleiner perkins NEA and Burson
furnitures so at that point we're really
off - they're off to the races and it
was really a very fun time
moved into a kind of a shoebox of an
office especially when you need lab
space 1800 feet we started packing in at
some point we were growing and we had
literally little cubbies set up on the
conference table of people working in
the copier copy room and it was a lot of
fun so we built an implant they ran it
for our first clinical trial and I kind
of told you the end of the story on this
bent a little bit and that sometimes the
first idea isn't always the best one
right and so we build this implant we
get in there we treat 40 patients and
fortunately safety was was very very
good no one got hurt but some patients
got efficacy and some of them didn't
right so it was working out really well
for some that was not working out quite
as well for others and simultaneously
we're feeling this healthcare
environment changing under our feet much
faster than we thought that we thought
that it would right so here we are we're
building an implantable device it's a
procedure it's invasive it's gonna take
a very long time to get approved and
actually get out into the market so
especially looking out and saying five
years from now what the hell was the
healthcare environment gonna look like
is this really what we should be
focusing on
there's also expensive for the payers
expensive for the patients and so
fortunately this coincided with us
actually having a really nice insight
and what we realized is actually that
our best performing patients despite
having an implant on one side
actually we're getting tearing on both
eyes now the reason that's really
exciting is because it turns out those
two eyes aren't connected right the only
way they're connected is through the
brain which tells us that we're actually
activating reflex so we got to thinking
and said okay is there another way we
can act a bit a reflex to make this
happen and actually Jim Loudoun and I
were done in Mexico eating fish tacos
there's Jim eating said fish tacos right
there and had this idea of actually
activating the nose so inside the walls
of the office we had this this we call
it affectionately called the reflex the
wasabi reflex so
everybody in the room who's ever put too
much wasabi under sushi kind of
backdraft in your nose right you know
exactly what this reflex is you got a
bunch of tears pouring down your face
you know but you may not know is that
actually for every single person in this
room right now this reflex is actually
active right now driving you're tearing
so unless you have a cold or allergies
you're breathing through your nose so
every breath that we take both in and
out very gently activates the same nerve
that the wasabi does and drives a third
of your tear production right now and so
it turns out that if you activate it
then it can be a really nice and
effective thing for dry patients so not
only will be able to get the better
efficacy from it but it really fit
within this this archetype of what we
were looking for for the healthcare
environment as well there's something
that was not invasive and better for the
patients it's cheaper for the payers
troupers cheaper for the patients
I provided a good practice building
opportunity which means the doctor can
actually provide this product out of
their office provide a revenue source
where they're getting cut and other
places it also provides a really nice
opportunity to leverage information
technology with a Bluetooth enabled
device so here's the device that has has
two components to it the blue part is a
rechargeable rechargeable electrical
stimulator device there's a little
disposable that goes on top and that
disposable has some hydrogel that allows
a kind of a connection to the nose and
doesn't mention it's Bluetooth capable
and has a digital companion app and
what's really nice about this is now we
can leverage the technology that that
this valley has developed for everything
else and introduced an IND opthamology
where it's never been there before and
what allows us to do is allows both the
patient and but very importantly the
physician to track how the patient's
doing what it also does is dry eyes
environmental disease so we can use
geolocation weather data and say all
right you know what you know using
humidity and wind and temperature etc
this it's going to be a good dry a day
or bad dry I do
something very important to these
patients and then frankly something as
simple as being able to leverage your
smart device to order refills right and
the same way that we order anything else
and to checked all the boxes right so we
as better for the patient better for the
healthcare provider we pulled it out of
the hospital system so there's no no
surgical procedure there it's cheaper
for the pairs it's less invasive and
less risky and therefore cleaner path
through the FDA unfortunately has been
very well received by the societies so I
will show you a quick video here you get
to see this thing in action so what
you're looking at before I start it and
this is a close-up of someone's eye the
bull's eye rings are a function of the
device and the light source that's on
there so it's not not anything funky
going on with the patient and what you
look at is the very the lower lid margin
there okay and so what you'll see the
patient just started using the device
within about 10 seconds or so you'll see
a pretty dramatic increase in the tear
lake there that's your production level
and what's also was really fun for us as
it turns out I mentioned there's
different components in the tear coming
from different organs and actually this
reflex activates all of them where our
first device was actually going after
one and that's something that's actually
very important from a clinical
perspective as well so this is
healthcare so we do clinical trials we
were I've completed seven trials today
treated almost 700 patients and the
device is currently sitting with the FDA
right now so fingers crossed we're
hoping we can launch this in the first
half of next year so as mentioned before
that we were acquired by allergen in
August of last year I did want to touch
on that as well so in addition to to the
obvious in terms of providing return for
the shareholders most importantly our
again increased this enormous lover for
us right so if we're a very small
company and we're trying to go out and
treat patients that are not only all
over the United States but frankly all
over the planet right it's really hard I
mean you got our one group at a time
it's something that Facebook advertising
alone isn't going to take care of
because you do have this complex
networking you the health care provider
to actually ultimately prescribe that
device an allergen they're the world
leader in the space right now right they
have sales representatives in the office
of 23,000 eye care professionals in the
US alone that's almost all of them
alright and what just a really
tremendous opportunity for us to be able
to make a really meaningful impact on
public health and in a very short order
at time I did also just want to touch
now that I've actually spent some time
in it in a big company and just and
reflect on it a little bit as well I'm
sort of in line with some other things
we've talked about in addition to kind
of this management of risk that I think
is is important I'm certainly to some of
our staff and I've also learned a lot
right I'm there I'm working into place
we're about to launch a product and
we're gonna launch it in a world-class
way right and learning from people who
are very very good at this people who
are scaling manufacturing learning how
to do that and I think that's also true
for for our staff as well being able to
come in and really learn from people who
are frankly some of the best in the
business
typically had some of these later-stage
parts parts of the product cycle and
again I'm making at this opportunity to
make impact and one of the things that
has been really fun about this and is
that there's money there right I mean I
mentioned when you're on the startup you
know you have confidence that there's
going to be the next check if you're
doing the right things but but frankly
there's a lot of uncertainty there and
when you're at a profitable business
there's a lot of resources and so
actually within our group we we have two
pipeline products that weren't there
when we started and actually some really
innovative folks within our group have
developed two new two new technology
ideas and they're they're up and running
and it's really nice to be in a place
where where that can happen and I think
that to echo sort of the the opportunity
for entrepreneurship as well I'm just
just relating that can
actually happen in a big company so I'm
gonna leave you there and what I am
gonna say is that this is just an
amazing time in healthcare and literally
this almost 20% of our entire economy
right that is largely untouched by the
types of technologies that this you know
20-mile radius
has been at transforming the world with
and it's a really exciting time to be
there and there's a lot of opportunity
not only to to come in and and move the
market with share but frankly to really
do a great thing for you know for our
community and for our country right and
we we we need it it's getting really
expensive we're having a hard time
keeping up with it so I hope that some
of you guys will take a look at
healthcare and and maybe take a look at
the Biodesign courses as well so with
that thank you very much
[Applause]
so sure so when you were finishing the
Biodesign program you set your threshold
then raising a Series A but you could be
essentially trying to get to that
freshman for a wild wouldn't what did
you know it was that way versus pursuing
yeah I think there was like a time
crunch there as well yeah so the
question was when it's not leaking kind
of magically time when you're gonna get
the financing and when we're so the
threshold was was this series a and how
do you sort of time that and especially
with respect to other opportunities
might be happening and you know it's not
easy right
you're constantly reading the tea leaves
I constantly tried to push out I'm you
know your hedge opportunities and say oh
look you know get few more months but
these things are really exciting about
this etcetera and then also frankly just
you know just really digging in and
trying to to drive people to closing in
the a I think one thing that has
certainly happened and what I would
recommend is to the extent possible in a
great position to do that as I would
talk to somebody who's experienced at
fundraising I think the way that I would
go and raise a Series A now is just so
different in the way that I would raise
that I raised it and the first time I
think that there's a lot of things that
you can do to really not only garner
interest and excitement but frankly
manage a process and because everybody
talks about running a competitive
process and how you try to get multiple
term sheets and you know really get the
best value for your company etc but the
reality is people don't reach the end at
the same time unless you really drive
them to do that and that's something
that I didn't actually learn until total
raising raising later money
so you have give this innovative digital
device I mean a ton of do you talk about
if you're using the data and data
science to make well the device they're
technically and also from a business
model for special yeah so the question
is basically how are we leveraging the
digital aspect of the the product in how
are we how is that driving both of the
business model but also the technical
side as well so I mean I think just as
data enables a lot of other things I
mean it's it's not valuable Internet of
itself per se but it can really be a
great enabler in our case we use it
again to enable care so it's something
that allows physicians to check in they
can look at a portal see how patients
are doing and you know this is Jones and
sorry you're not I'm feeling good but
you know maybe it's not a big surprise
because you haven't you ever been using
your treatment again also in terms of
providing direct value to the patient
from looking at the environment and
other things that directly impact try I
but where I think things can be actually
incredibly powerful from a business
perspective is that in lots of
industries and the customer relationship
is the relationship with the customer is
very direct right so Google knows more
about me than I know about me right
because I do everything on Google but in
the healthcare space when someone writes
a prescription for drugs you don't even
know who has the script right and you
literally don't even that person is
completely anonymous and so what that
does is it makes it really hard to to
know what could be making things better
for that patient how do you make
patients more compliant and how do you
impact care in a meaningful way there I
think this is something that's and it's
really powerful with a technology like
this as you have that direct link you
had that direct customer relationship
and you can you can nudge them right and
you can say look you know you're not
using the the way that it should or the
doctor can nudge them and say look
you're not using it the way you should
etcetera so
so one major difference between a
software startup and medical technology
startup pretty much so here's the FDA
there's CMS can you comment on how the
landscape is now or maybe how they're
trying to streamline the process to get
faster from provocations market yeah so
the question was a big difference
between software and the healthcare and
is that it's highly regulated right and
then in addition to the regulation to
even be able to get onto the market you
have this entire reimbursement side that
has to be covered too right so not only
does it have to be approved but somebody
has to agree that they're gonna pay for
it and so how does that impact things
and and how how are things potentially
changing so what I would say is that in
some ways it's very tempting to think
about those things as barriers because
frankly they are barriers right I mean
you got to go through a lot to do that
and you have to have knowledge of the
system right you have to understand what
this regulation thing is all about to be
able to get a product under the market
and you have to understand what this
reimbursement thing is all about to get
there what I will tell you is I mean
it's a great thing I mean Here I am I am
a total neophyte you have to spun this
thing out of Stanford just four years
ago and I don't have some high school or
at pally high coming up with a
competitive version of our product
that's going to launch immediately after
right it's there's some complexity there
and but there's an incredible network of
people in this valley and beyond that
understand the nuance and frankly it's
not rocket science right and so it
doesn't take a lot to understand it you
just have to be able to get in and get
that understanding and then play by the
rule and what you got on the other side
actually it's it's it's really a really
tremendous barrier that actually ends up
being very protective and there are
things that are working to make it to
make it go faster but inherently I mean
these are they're long processes right
now but I think that's part of the
trade-off I mean the markets are equally
as large even a very tiny fraction of a
three
dollar market is still can be a
multi-billion dollar market right I mean
it's still enormous markets and so
there's really enormous opportunity but
you're not competing with you have
intellectual property you have FDA you
have reimbursement barriers that really
prevent competitors from coming into the
space so you spoke about moving to
allergen for Alligator how that can take
more resources and stuff I'm kind of
curious I'm like I'd like a leadership
level the one from you and your
partner's kind of running your own
company your own team numpy a part of a
much much bigger organization yeah so
the question is about leadership and
going from something that's a very small
company and starting off in a real
partnership leveled even in a growing
startup frankly and then transitioning
to now you know an employer company with
some 25,000 employees in it you know
what is what is that like and what does
that mean and frankly it's actually very
different and one of the things that
I've actually really valued about my
learning experience I'm at Allergan is
just it's a very different type of
leadership right when you're going and
even on the startup phase where you
start it's you've got it's you in some
buddies around a table everybody's
involved in every decision right you're
sitting there and you're making calls
and you're going off and doing things
you don't have to have any real
structure from a management perspective
and as that grows you have to both
evolve and leadership and management and
there's a distinction there so
leadership in terms of setting vision
and setting culture and that really has
to start becoming real as you start
having more than just a few people
around the table and that also is
leadership and a startup or you're
selling the vision so our vision is we
wanted to be the world leader and dry
eye right I mean it's got to be it's got
to be ambitious right because you're
you're going out there and you're trying
to change the world and if you're not if
you're not shooting for that
world-changing thing then you're never
going to get there and setting an
environment that's a nice a good place
to work for others it's
but also setting up a management system
that is able to kind of tolerate and
make functional a larger increasing
that's group of people and so we've gone
from having no management system that
was the whiteboard and you know three
people around a table making calls to
having a formal management system in a
small private operating company so now
you know been this huge matrix based
organization right and so there's people
in other parts of the organization that
are making really really important calls
on what we're doing the leadership is
actually previously it was it was my
team those reporting to me and then
actually about to the world in terms of
being an evangelist for you know for the
company and now actually a lot of my
effort is spent internally yeah my
spoons I spent a lot of time with
internal sales right so I'm going in and
selling other parts of the organization
on what we're doing and and really have
to influence people you know that there
aren't reporting to me often times and
it's actually it requires a different
style and you have to motivate people in
different ways and so it's it has been
different but it but frankly it's it's
been part of the fun of this this
experience
somebody else so beside in hindsight now
before the fun besides in the funding it
was there another indication that you
had that you were on to something
compelling in hindsight besides just the
fact that you're an external VC invest
in you is there another milestone that
you think you onto something yeah so the
question was there any what were the
other signals that we were onto
something important as opposed to just
this funding event right and they're
frankly they're the same signals that
you get for whether or not you're on to
a right life partner you're on you're on
to you know the anything the right
anything else you do in your life and
that's are people around you excited
about it are you getting positive
signals from it or you're getting
negative signals right and and frankly
it doesn't it's not just this endure but
it evolves and there's constantly
negative signals but can you keep
evolving that in iterating very very
quickly to where people you know there's
momentum in that and it's actually
people getting more and more excited or
is it something where it's like okay you
know well I'll take this meeting because
you know you're at Stanford and your
professor professor with the courtesy of
sitting down with you for 20 minutes and
or is it something where people are they
sit in there like oh my gosh actually
this is really interesting you know you
should think about this this this and so
that's that's a lot of it yeah and so is
a new administration and it was
potential change to the award will care
out something that a perspective yeah so
the question is what is what is trumping
for healthcare right and what was Trump
name for anything I don't know so
there's frankly it's a big question and
because it's I think there's a lot of
uncertainty around what the agenda will
be and and I think there's uncertainty
not only in terms of communication but I
think that that frankly there's
uncertainty within the administration as
to what the position is going to be
there has been talk of
either completely dismantling or
meaningfully changing the Affordable
Care Act that certainly will impact
healthcare I think there's also been
talk from the Trump campaign about
maintaining some sort of system that
promotes high insurance percentages
within the country as well what I do
think is that fundamentally I think that
the same problems are going to be the
same problems the same things that are
driving all this tremendous change I
mean we're we're kind of tapping out of
this 17 18 percent of GDP you know even
if it goes to 19 or something I mean
it's still it's still an issue and
whether or not we're dealing with at 95
percent of insured population or an 85
percent insured population seem to be
the same sorts of things but it may have
some impact on how acute it is or is not
also what's the thing if you insert
something under those it's too late
sneezing yeah so the question is how
does the device work right and does it
does it activate sneezing and actually I
would say the first time or to use it
with patients often do sneeze because
you've got something in your nose you're
activating these nerves and the same
thing that if you were to get something
stuck up there your body might try to
sneeze it's really those first couple of
times it activates that and but you saw
in the video I mean it's literally it's
10 seconds or so most patients use it
twice a day so you leave it in your
bathroom use it in the morning they use
it in the evening and basically use it
until they get the effect yeah what are
the side effects and what are this has
some of the things from a clinical
perspective that we read up against and
frankly beyond kind of the occasional
sneeze that happens and one of the
things that's interesting actually is
that the tears actually drain into your
nose and that's actually part of the
function of this entire reflex so those
tears wash
the wasabi and you're watching really
sad movie and our sad election perhaps
and her really cried you start sniffling
right and that's nibbling is as a
function of those tears being in the
nose and so there is some sniffling that
can't occur particularly if you really
give yourself a good a good dose but one
thing we've been extremely and trying to
think I think the other side effect that
it occasionally happens is if patients
have a really really dry nose and you
place something in your nose then you
might get a little a little bit of
spotting of blood and but one of the
things that's been really great about
this particular technology is that it is
so low risk and it's something that from
a trial perspective the FDA formerly
designated as a non significant risk
product and it's so great because now we
can actually reach a much wider fraction
those 30 million people who have dry eye
because it is so low risk I'm get
effective unlike the procedure roll
treatment that we had medical industry
and like looking for in efficiencies how
did you narrow it down from the hundreds
of thumb so you found to just one it
seems that you the difficult to choose
now so the question is you know we have
these three hundred and some-odd needs
how do we kind of narrow it down to one
it seems like it what's been difficult
yes it is and and so really there's
there's a few things I mean we applied
kind of a high level filter of what what
is a a genuine clinical problem and what
has commercial potential and what I mean
by that and I think this is actually
quite true well beyond healthcare that's
you've got to look at at what is the
potential value what is the market
potential of this product and is the
investment that's required to get there
to actually get this out there
commensurate with that opportunity right
so if you're gonna have to go through
and some big longer and the healthcare
projects aren't cheap right I mean I
think getting a medical device to market
on average is 70 to 100 million bucks
right so
big dollars and if you can't be
convinced that at the end of that you're
gonna have hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars in revenue and then
it's really a tough it's a tough call to
make in terms of being able to garner
the investment on the front end to do it
now on the other hand if you're going to
be making a very something that is less
intensive I'm in terms of price and
you're making it a surgical instrument
something like that then maybe it's
hundreds of thousands or you know baby
whatever it is to get there then the
market opportunity dozen have to be the
same either we rightly or wrongly we're
looking for a big opportunity and that
was that was one of her filters and then
frankly you know we're looking at these
different problems and dry I was the one
where we had you know had the idea of
how to fix it so that's what that was
part of the tip yes the opportunities to
apply some of the learnings on the
design side and for medical device
experience to therapeutics and the world
of molecules in the more traditional
pharma sense yeah so the question is is
there anything that can be applied from
this device side to to the pharma beside
I'm the short answer is yes I'm actually
very very excited about biopharma right
now and there's a lot of reasons but
some of the challenges on the pricing
side don't exist to the same degree
anyway obviously it's been a political
football but to the same degree on on
the drug side as they do on the device
side and I think there is that
opportunity I think it's but I think it
tends to be a certain blend a certain
type of therapeutic so for example we
actually had a drug program inoculate
yeah we splendid out into another
company and that company is an
independent operating company right now
and that was a pharmaceutical that
rather than going through and having
this really key insight we we've
realized that there's this receptor on
this you know on this cell that nobody
else realized was there we've you know
gone through and this
the molecule to go in there and tag that
receptor instead we said actually look
you could possibly activate the same
pathway the same diesel pathway frankly
I'm using a pharmaceutical spray as well
and so we went through a pretty
organized process of actually going down
screening molecules so we were screening
molecules that were already out in the
marketplace right
somebody else had already taken them to
a certain certain level and and it turns
out that the ideal molecule was actually
sitting in a company that that was going
to funked the molecule they'd run it
through phase 2 trials it was very very
safe but didn't treat gastroparesis and
so so we bought it off them and so yes I
think you can still use those same
techniques but I think it it's maybe not
on as much on the discovery side and
that's certainly on the development side